you
you
hmm hello and welcome
why on earth why on earth how probably
this is kind of weird
how do I do I change that just a second
how do I actually get this right
this one yes okay so let's get going
[Laughter]
okay welcome to all of you sorry for the
somewhat somewhat weird start to that I
had to get the actual picture right so
what am I going to do tonight
I'm not sure I'm really not sure what
I'm what I would like to do I was
thinking of trying to get my rating up
I've got my go back is that possible I
know that's my own stream that's kind of
ridiculous my blitz rating is kind of
kind of low you know
two four six okay I have improved a
little bit but I was thinking maybe it's
an idea to get this a little bit higher
and I wonder what the best way is yeah I
could play a tournament one I could just
play a couple of three minutes games
against higher rated opposition also I
know I can try you know
I can try if I go here and let's say
create a game what are we going to do I
mean I can do 3-0 it's a bit quick word
and let's say
something like that does that make sense
standard real time let's see what
happens see if I get some some games and
I don't get any I check the lobby okay
and nothing too too high and five plus
three is a little bit long ninja TV okay
let's see what the ninja TV is up to get
the Scotch four nights had this opening
on the board only yesterday actually in
a tournament gamer
and I made the draw against quite strong
international master but I was still a
little bit disappointed because I am had
a really nice position and I somehow
couldn't get this I couldn't get this to
be more than just a bit better somehow I
mean okay I was I wanted to go before
here I don't know if it's good let's try
this I usually play this with c4 this
kind of setup and yeah this is part of
my chest of a repertoire yes so I wonder
oftentimes a move like um clean 2g three
years AG is interesting I'm not sure
about this but I can it's interesting
no I don't sell my autograph but it's
kind of funny I'm not a celebrity so it
doesn't make any sense
so I try to trade to increase my control
over the c5 Squared's the idea okay oh
okay I think I'll just take this and I'm
happy to try this yes true I played
against because lots of that was the
league game yesterday
I had a pretty nice ending when I had I
just had a bad bad moment I played to
draw at the end I had a pretty bad
moment where I simply I simply
overlooked I would look at a simple move
in the king of porn ending okay if he
takes your pawn takes rook takes e5 a7
is hanging so what is the app tonight
you four or something I can also just
play this this is a slightly better
position for me no I am I am drinking
tea it's my usual beverage for some time
now but I am I finished my evening my
evening tea a while ago had some green
tea with with some orange flavor was
pretty nice but I don't want to drink
late in the evening
yeah
now I prefer team it has more variety
than coffee there's nothing wrong with
coffee of course but just I never drank
much coffee actually the smoking was bad
it really was but the coffee was always
kind of what we moderate yeah this is
going to be very draws I'm offering a
draw here yes I've got to a tournament
coming up actually I moved 27 rupees
seven blood that the rook he had played
King away you know yeah I cannot go Ruby
Sam
yeah that was not very exciting at some
point I probably missed something
yes I have a tournament coming up okay I
can go to a rematch sure why not
it's a decently rated opponent
yeah Everton can I'm going to play a
really nice one looking forward to that
a lot it will start in
[Music]
for weeks a little bit more than four
weeks I'm going to play a tournament
playing the absolutely same thing no and
we can get the same position man it's
almost the same position and I'm going
to play a tournament in San Sebastian in
in Spain
I wonder what German and I know that
it's called Baskin lund to the Basques
Basques yeah anyway I mean I think
people from there would protection you
object that it is Spain yeah anyway I'm
going to play tournament in Thunder
Bastion that were going to be nice open
tournament the Basques it's an open
tournament nine round swiss yeah this is
a super sharp line that should be bad
for white but it's it's obviously a bit
crazy this is a good line form for for
me but it is
yeah I know I have been to that part of
Spain in the form
I only I didn't know the span of the the
the right to that terms yeah 97 King d7
98 King takes c6 this is in fact how it
is played and this whole thing is
supposed to be great for black yeah
total business okay so this is this I
don't know
so it's night day is hanging c6 I mean
if I just take it
97 King d89 takes 8 and then some Bishop
age 3 yeah this is probably very good
for me I just wonder if this is the best
I could also just finish it right
through here but I wonder if this isn't
good oh I did not think about this move
at all
I don't think of this at home I did not
think of this at home okay I mean
currently I'm material up I just wonder
where to go here and I don't know if
neither for as strong yeah of course he
could have taken money on d7 with the
fork but I don't I don't know if it was
good I can with Bishop a tree I get the
whole stuff back and I have an attack
I mean this is a funny position I'm one
pawn down but the whole situation is
extremely lucky and I could have taken
the night which would have been strong
probably no I'm threatening this and the
knight is hanging should be very good he
also cannot move the knight it's pinned
looks like a win
yeah what's the chess player I respect
most don't really know I think all the
the top class players I extremely strong
so I cannot say that there's some
somebody in particular that would be
extraordinary like somebody nobody else
would mention also okay so Carlton is
playing Tang at the moment oh my
goodness they are playing what are they
playing ultra bullet they play 45
seconds this is crazy I don't know I
don't know if I want actually because
I've done this the commentary on the on
the on the ultra bullet and it was kind
of it was kind of funny you know I don't
I don't know if it this is a good thing
to do we have because it gets extremely
extremely weird yeah castle will destroy
tang this is not a question he's just
like bye-bye am i of the better player I
mean by a mile so he will win this very
clearly yeah I want to play some games
if they are on for four longer I can do
some cubed sing and I'd like to get my
rating a little bit a little bit higher
now it's I think it's it's reasonable
you can you can you can do this but I've
done this like two weeks ago for a long
for a long streak for a long time and
it's kind of weird to do this you know
because they it's I mean I would be
totally happy to comment on blitz or it
was like two minutes but Archer bullet
is very very extreme and it I hate you
again it would be a slaughter anyway I
mean that will be very very clearly in
Magnus's favor
yeah I don't get a game though that's a
problem
maybe 2300 is too high I don't know they
probably many people will watch and I
think tang is also streaming
yeah I don't get a game either this is
the problem you know what I should do is
actually at one point what I want to do
is there is there is some there is some
I don't know um plug-in or something
okay I got a game and there is some
plug-in that allows twitch chat
participators to to take part in surveys
and bit polls so I could actually ask
the chat okay what do you want to see
what do you want me to do and then you
can have a vote yeah I think this is a
good good thing to do because I'm unsure
sometimes what is a majority choice of
the of the chat okay this is a fairly
normal
fairly normal looking French advanced
advanced you can use straw poll and
stuff like that but there is something
built-in something that is directly
connected to to twitch somehow twitch
Paul overlay I actually did not see that
I was offer on this pond okay no I don't
have a bot yet installed I have to do it
there are some technical things so
missing in this channel definitely so
somehow by weirdest transpositions we've
gotten
we've gotten something that you usually
get from the Milner Barre gambit of the
French advance White has some
compensation maybe not enough
compensation but it's um yeah
we'll see d4 bishop f2 it's not a good
idea for him I think I thought that it's
not good because I get the e4 square I
would seem
no I've read I I read my system and I
also read chess practice yeah I I don't
I'm not a huge fan in chess practice
there are those games at noon which is
played and most of his opposition I
think they're just so dreadfully bad you
can't prove any sort of theory against
those players like not developing pieces
is great you could prove it against them
I think most of his opponents ever at
best at best club players and some of
the commentary is so dreadfully
dreadfully wrong that it really wrecks
my nerves yes yes absolutely wacky stuff
in there that is that makes no sense at
all okay so I'm going to open this
position this is intending this capture
and this invasion so um what's going on
here I can take on f5 potentially or
Yahoo p1 this is simple love I'll do
that just try to take them
I'm not I cannot really tell I don't
really have an opinion on Jeremy summons
books absolutely not
I only have one book and I haven't I
haven't really used it all that much
this thing reassess your chest so I had
I don't have a very clear opinion no 20
miles died by the year 2000 or 2100 a
very interesting creative player okay so
I think I'll take it
no trying to take this and then take on
the form let's put my pressure here
don't know if this is a good idea yes ma
Maggie I cannot comment on a book that I
have not read you know like the the
Selman book yeah that's not great
what kind of time control I said three
they're wrong we both try to play for
mate but he has ran out of time
yeah dose up year yeah I know that I
absolutely know that it's an Austrian
beer brand and I can tell you a funny
little story about about discursive yeah
I have I played some tournaments in said
Hungary or Hungaria Hungary right and
when I was going though going there for
the first time I I went together with a
friend who had been there a couple of
times already for tournaments and he is
he the first evening it said I know a
great restaurant yeah we should go where
they have been there many times and they
have great food and everything's great
yeah let's go there and and then we went
down and and he said you know this is
the restaurant it's called Gaza yeah
let's go to the Gaza restaurant and like
I had to tell him you know um this is
not the name of the restaurant this is
just a beer brand yeah it's not like
every other restaurant has the same name
you know it's a beer brand it was a
great restaurant
so everything was fine but I was quite
funny too when you told me let's go to
Gaza okay must be a pretty big chain
than yeah okay so and going for this
going for this in my ancient line my
score is so good yeah with this it's
completely crazy
yes well played bear up he's playing it
right he's playing it right not trading
on b5 is actually a good idea yeah this
is I had this kind of stuff on the board
so often it's beyond belief especially
you hope so white does not want to win
this game it seems his content with
trying to try to beg for a draw let's
see
now what has no way to open the position
anymore absolutely no way I have an idea
I have root therefore which is not in
itself doing much my blundered g5 this
is the way to lose it let's go back okay
I think I go age six so then I can
actually move the Queen let's do this
now I don't see you think that he plays
for a draw because he sees the I am
title it's fairly high rated so I would
like to get this rook over to f8 this is
maybe a way to do it
yeah oh I have not paid I did not pay
attention here I it was that stupid I
didn't pay any attention you know I'm
actually in trouble
that that's pretty sick it's pretty sick
that I'm in trouble
but this Queen doesn't have many squares
right if I take this I'm threatening but
should be aired
he might just take knowledge for very
very weird everything
my screen is trapped still not an easy
position Bishop g7 maybe coming not sure
I don't have much time to really figure
it out this route gage ain't business is
still kind of tricky I mean it's got
some material for the Queen it's not
like it's super easy I think okay yeah I
thought simply here but probably not
home cannot take let's do this
yeah pieces look a little bit awkward
take a leave for now look if aid would
have been interesting and the bishop was
just hanging oh my god instead of
blunder the free and queen what is sick
game my was thus it is a sick game I
should have won like a million times and
a one long time I have us crazy
sorry I couldn't I couldn't watch his
chin at all
I was simply caught up in this game
I was completely completely bad
[Music]
yeah it's it's always very tough and I
recommend good books on the agent under
players trying to improve hmm yeah there
are so many many books around if I click
new opponent is that the same surge it's
the same surges you're sure
okay you know it's still on that match
against ten so I'm going to play a
little bit myself and then have a quick
look what they're doing I would like to
know how this how this turns out a six
years ago where for him this is my my
life against against the modern I think
this is fairly comfortable for white
okay Castle short kept so long I don't
know I'm going to cancel short thing I
think it should be a comfortable
position for white just have more space
I'm a huge fan of having space I have to
admit yeah once the viewercount say my
et viewers yeah it's a very busy evening
there are many streams going on Magnus
is playing yeah Fiona is streaming many
many good things going on so I'm just um
[Music]
centralizing here and then see what
happens I just want to keep the space
advantage what are you doing there yes
to go back alright and f4
she really really really asked me to
expand like that I'll do that
9s sucks
looks pretty awful is it take with the
Bishop Knight c8 and now how am I going
to meet him here
this is coverage the night to eat form
maybe I know it's got 923 but I don't
really think this is something that
black can afford would be weird
let's get this to you form and now the
ideas Bishop g5 Queen aged six mate okay
so I can't bring the Bishop to g7
yeah why not
okay I wanted yeah yeah okay let's go
Bishop g7 there is night c-54 made on h7
but there's also a roof on the third to
take on age seven and then make a like
if the book is here I take on each
segment made on h8 at the end and looks
very dominating would be quite
surprising if he finds a way out some
age five
ie resigned ok again to rematch let's do
that and ok I just go eat five that's
when I my best yeah you know if you are
if you have a fear candle position and
the opponent is actually putting putting
a bishop on your g7 squares black you
know that something went terribly wrong
okay so how interesting did I make a
mistake there against his wacky move
water I applied the delay devil scammed
which is totally incorrect but maybe
it's okay how how it turned out
I probably is it looks a bit weird
Jim no I have to go d5 unfortunately
that looks bad I made some mistake there
and he got away with this bad by opening
yes unfortunately this is the
possibility that I gave him yeah I have
no one move now I have no one else
[Music]
threatening to take their they ain't
singing and everything
and a-five is simply hanging I always
hate to lose against such bad openings
but okay anyway they have no move I just
lose lots of material lose a piece
simply
I probably would just take only five he
played the delayed Evans which is
completely incorrect completely
incorrect as castles helps white
absolutely doesn't help void yeah I live
in the western part of Germany North
rhine-westphalia close to Dusseldorf and
Cologne which most people will probably
know okay yeah it's just completely lost
just hope you can always hope but I'm
just lost to be a c5 is a small threat
but mmm what's covered
maybe as some kind of discovery by the
night what is that area famous for yeah
I don't know if we are famous for
anything in particular
probably for coal and steel mills from
back in the day and the carnival maybe
yeah that's there's some truth to that
yeah I should I should probably just
resign but I always feel it was really
unnecessary hmm maybe you go you go -
what did i do they actually bishop pen
Knight f6 was was wrong here
yeah just Bishop d6 then yeah and then
White's just pawn down here for
absolutely zilch for nothing but I came
so I need some revenge the game before
was that completely complete route
okay get the same kind of position he
does not seem to mind to get it again
which I find quite remarkable next
position was basically unplayable from
early on in that game I am I going to
withdraw that I'm just centralized yeah
in the in the I know what area we
basically have one it's just one big
city and you don't really recognize that
much when you change from yeah I don't
know I do spoke to Sno Oberhausen and so
on so one yeah it's given me given me
this again yeah he doesn't seem to like
his Bishop I at all Jeff found quite
remarkable it's it's the most important
piece that you have was black and he
just gives it away I'm just going to
play for an attack here again I know he
can't take b2 and so on but this attack
is going to be very dangerous even even
party of five is dangerous
yeah and I'm okay I'm take take it I
don't mind
yeah the bastion zbrush turn the world's
tallest Grandmaster I think he stood as
yes those um those chess events in
shopping centers it's supposed to be
really nice
I have never been to one but a friend of
mine a clock made of mine told me that
it is it was very nicely done and a very
very attractive event so I mean it's
always good to have and I mean I know
the bus young from really back in the
day having played in in junior
competitions almost 30 years ago and
he's good at those those things it's
also very young
very very good with kids and so on
it's a it's pretty nice yeah I don't
know my tech the tech that a solitaire
is maybe not like 100% sound but it's
dangerous I think it's very dangerous
what is he doing now I'm taking one of
those and this I mean this is just a
piece of huh
he I'm a piece of what is some Alex
compensation for being a piece down I
don't think there is any compensation
okay so Ruby five and I'm going to cover
that no I can't even get the King here
right just put the King on to e2
look the pawn yeah I think there was
enough remember I'm still kind of kind
of an amused F for losing this game
earlier against this wacky Evans gambit
but but okay um yeah I played him the
form that was this this very game
there's been luring game out of the
Spanish oh no he goes for this sinister
swathe you know that I'm screwing this
up right
sinister suavity thanks for subscribing
yeah there was a twitch primal
subscription so if any of you have a
Amazon Prime account
ya know depth you have one free
subscription to a twitch channel and it
doesn't cost you anything really it's
completely free it's part of the Amazon
Prime and package so definitely would be
very happy if you subscribe me subscribe
to my channel using your your Amazon
Prime account ok night she's home what's
going on here you have to take it yeah
it's really cool there's no extra cost
for you and for me it's absolutely the
same a benefit let's say compared to a
regular let's say subscription
so we got this and ending out of the out
of them Italian I wonder I just wondered
yeah my night has no squares him my
night has no squares
if 6f3 fh 5 fe 4 takes on d4 that is
kind of interesting
Oberlin f4 didn't expect that to happen
do I just take one there Kim cheek
you cannot take
okay I can I can can cover this trying
to cover this time but with the King I
know I'm I think unreasonable shape
which doesn't mean I'm better yeah so
don't miss interpret what I'm saying but
I think I'm kind of alive at least I
came I don't know if this is a good idea
but I'm - oh no way kick with the rook
frigging look I can't take on d4 I could
take on before he blundered upon and I
forgot really for God that he could take
with the damn rock crazy this is totally
crazy
why just blundered the most important
pawn and instead of just taking it I
played in the other and then the wrong
move water yeah white is completely
outplayed but I've got no time got no
time
yeah probably it's ugly he still has
some drawing chances but I have no no
time whatsoever got no time how I said
was pretty EOTech what I did
it was you can just take your phone and
then he just just just resigns him just
resigns okay so is there anything else
going on it's true for something again
this arm guy okay it's win a nice climb
in the row so Nemo
I'm not really good at 3:02 be honest
I'm better three plus two is my best
time control
yeah I should have paid some attention
glancing at the cheat could be tricky
I just blunder grandmother's porn by
looking too much at the church
oh yeah itself it's bad but at least
there there are some fighting chances
him simply because of the good
development
I'm taking this I don't know if six
maybe it's not enough no the reason why
I'm playing three zero instead of five
zero here is you get you get you get
more opponents it's just like it seems
to be the preferred time control for
most players
I prefer 5 0 or 3 2 3 2 s my best time
control
and 3 plus 2i i don't lose on time ever
like and i sometimes manage to just win
the the the winning positions ok well
what are you doing here what is this
person doing
I wonder don't quite get what black is
doing I think I'm getting real
compensation by now yeah you get 3 0 is
easy to get a position somehow yeah now
I'm attacking this and I'm threatening
age 5 and what is that doing I don't get
it
okay truth
I miss underestimated him
cannot take it to you for unfortunate
them
soon have some compensation but maybe
not enough
[Music]
yeah
the misunderestimated I know where
that's coming from
[Music]
yeah it's got this check out fortunately
ah that was a terrible there was a
terrible game Jim I really got some nice
compensation all of a sudden okay but of
course the opening play pretty badly
I still wonder if I'm not having some
decent compensation there I didn't see a
five I mean I can't simply take on c3
and probably win and then aged five I
don't know okay so let me I want to
check one thing I want to see how the
scores Magnus is just looking right
22:12 this is pretty good for penguin
it's more than Earth than I thought it's
really more than her thought oops oops
yeah yeah Magnus was just an exchange of
and has a complete control
nicely done - put everything
montes my five and now ice to win this
ending which should be done easily for
him at least as easy
yeah winning very quick a blanket from
Dino time no opinions secure the draw
there that's good good stuff there too
to cross in the row that you expand from
like somebody yet Angus extremely fast
he is extremely fast I've played one
bullet game against Andrew tang and just
one and the game was totally one-sided I
was winning the whole time but at the
end we had like I had 15 seconds and he
had 20 or so in a regular 1-0 and he won
on time in such a simple fashion like I
had absolutely no chance like absolutely
no chance he's got 2,500 roughly I think
he's not actually a grandmaster and I
still think this is wrong by glitch s to
put GM titles or people who are supposed
to get it in a couple of weeks but he
has everything together of course he's
got the writing and the norms but he
doesn't have the title actually which i
think is bad that they put it on anyway
but very quick play Webber was
yeah yeah it's it's extremely it's an
extreme speed yeah
it looks very good for white nice shot
yeah
Queen TX g 6l with the pin yet so I'm
here to go in now the pressure on e5 is
tremendous you mean the white places
rubbish you mean this time control or
this OMS there was a big blunder there
yeah I mean okay this is
you know only has a vague relation to
chance of a loss but it's too fast it's
too fast for me for let's say to play
many games but I enjoyed that one bullet
game it's just mindless fun so why not
but what I don't get is if people like
do it for hours and hours and hours em
like just once in a while it's it's kind
of okay yeah that looks bad for like
really bad it's a piece down for for
nothing at all and yeah I have no clue
if kappa blanka and Laska would have
been interested in playing playing
bullets yes i mean kappa blanka
certainly was a gambling time and lastly
is tough to say I mean Laska as a chess
player I was a very practical player
mostly focused it was a very strong
tactical player I you don't see the
score right Magnus is leading by birth
wife in this session just by 5 and 10 is
doing a really great job there no just
in my form
yeah Alaska was a of course
the scientists a math art ition so his
his chest and fact was a bit untypical
of what is what he did
outside of chess because a chest he
wasn't scientists or name somebody
explora at all Laska was action
absolutely terrible in openings for
example Lasker once I started out as a
coffee house player this is not a wrong
way to put it and it sounds a little bit
demeaning but it's really what he wants
you he started to play in getting the
students coffee houses is this
environment he was an extremely strong
coffee house player of course you know
absolutely amazingly strong that's a
really much terrible in the opening I
mean there are some openings that he
play they were really absolutely
atrocious
so it's this season I draw him yeah
probably
this is I would have been a drawing like
just hit the King kept the king passive
and this is completely silly right
didn't get a griddle drawn I find this
like it's completely pointless to click
this to the end of days
yeah that looks like a completely normal
game let's say pretty standard
conservative Italian game where in fact
here black is clearly worse to try an
analysis of this time format the Queen
on c5 is extremely strong combined with
the route to a7 and there are tons of
weaknesses in black stamp nice one
wanting to a great great ending
yeah the both be pawns for now I try and
try it for commentary and this is also
okay
I even blame he's doing very well here
tang the thought you would get totally
annihilated but that's not the case it's
really very its competitive it's really
competitive I know - we found a funny
major you you saw it mate rookie 5 mate
yeah no main line we got here of the
rune felt black tries for a closed
center and then put whoops
oops what did Magnus do there that was a
big one big blunder oh man that's not
going to work
what's there what's the score desist
nonsense England Cambodian a dead won't
work
yeah and I don't think Magnus is looking
so fresh somehow there's some some hot
decisions even getting given the time
control okay that's a very nice ending
for white c4
how do you keep that it's currently plus
floor for Magnus in this match 22 to 18
d45 d5 just e5d 596 93 Queen e7 Bishop
f4 is just excellent forward yeah here
Magnus has a piece of ending when you
select to win it with 12 seconds on the
clock
not that many left
yeah good night to colonial it's a big
night I started drama instead of wind I
think it's a winner
no it's Bishop f4 the mission before a
check yeah bridges it's just winning I
think it's very good for white I'm very
in Swiss we should be to Queen txb to
Knight c3 is just a lot better for white
it's a gambit okay so we call him okay
what's going on
and why does the peas up here hey it's
doing really well yeah yeah that's a
total win yeah Andrew tang is doing
really well there if you look at the
last couple of games I don't see the
score but then asked five nine London
the last ten his up six up five points
it's a lot my aim is to leaving this but
last couple of games were really in on
tanks favor yeah well you never know how
other circumstances are such an edge i
anyway of the players could be drunk or
whatever you have I know that I'm
totally useless light and bullet a
bullet chest what what Magnus do that
blundered everything I know I'm totally
useless in bullets as if I'm and kind of
[Music]
I'm not in top shape
[Music]
yeah thanks for the follow yeah here
Magnus has some it's somewhat weird
Hedgehog type of position wow man this
is this should be it's very much better
for like Queenie's recheck and natural
for services just around the corner and
there's no check tongue has no check
which is the end yeah so there was a win
for cars I got up an exchange leave it
should be right above right up Magnus's
any that same us this is an ending where
white is just a little bit better and
what story a counselor doesn't play the
exchange for exchange rib which is I
think you know it's it's certainly an
opening that I think you would do do
well in but it's it's believed to be on
the top level to to have yeah doesn't
have enough for conflict that same and
gives chances to to to to screw up
public but blitz weapon they both have
two thousand eight hundred and exactly
the same rating yeah it's a surprisingly
even match I think yeah Magnus has the
wings for for the here for for being a
patron only chest which he has to be I
mean he'd he is always you know in turn
a ting his tournament wins back by the
way there is a new titled
tournament the the titled arena I think
it's called I think on March 1st is the
next event and I think I cannot play
that so I would see if I can maybe do
cubits some of it but I don't think I
can claim after I have to see yeah they
have it at some time where I have to
teach our belief but I have to check
this sometimes I can know I can
reschedule lessons and it works out yeah
here yeah Magnus has blundered upon but
he's gotten some pretty good
compensation now it's a fantastic
mission on d6 and all the white pieces
look good nanite comes to d4 now what
mistakes comes and this is great for
white and he's gotten one time so this
this looks like a win for the world
champion the rukon on g6 I just want to
say looks really really uncomfortable
and it was dropping from quickly yeah GG
3 is inviting this age 5 business note
that it is fantastic but them
ok now Magnus has won four in a row or
some and this is a pretty awful position
now ok it's complicated so definitely
anything can happen over the bishop on
here for not surprisingly trapped it has
no squares in order to go with you but
the position is so very messy blacks
King is right wide open and now at this
kind of time control yeah anything can
happen
yeah and another win five in a row
enough Don yes my how many hours of
sleep do you need yeah I don't know are
there big different system I am the only
dead much usually like 6 to 7 hours
that looks that looks like black [ __ ]
winner maybe some trickery Bishop III oh
my god
that could be made Wow look at it mate
and h6 doesn't help pretty nice and one
zero this is quad couldn't I was very
lucky for Magnus of course he didn't
plan that before I guess when you blend
that everything but it worked out
Oh Oh big blunder my dream of blunder is
wrong
yeah Nishimura master this is my title
that we don't have in Germany and some
however used in the US and Canada in
some other land some other countries I
guess always find it a little bit weird
that these titles count towards some
that those times count for those title
tournaments because they are completely
there they're different let's say the
requirements are completely different so
this is seven in a row from Mengele so
he's leading by nine again I guess we've
got a hosting one you okay I haven't
really figured out how that hosting
works oh eight in a row should I host
other channels would it help somehow
yeah my thoughts on the feeder bank
accounts being frozen no particular
thoughts I haven't really read this I
mean I read that this is that's happened
but I haven't checked out any details of
what exactly is the reason and
everything it's not very surprising I
mean feud is basically just a mob so
it's no big surprise if anything is
happening there that's a really really
tough time ending
what's going on here 9:22 is stuck just
stuck yeah so tennis has broken this the
street yeah so um I wanted to watch a
little bit it's it's I think it's quite
it's quite entertaining to watch 45 is
actually a little bit let's say more
watchable than 30 seconds it really is a
somewhat somewhat of a difference but
let's see if you don't mind I had a
pretty I had a pretty em pretty tough
weekend yeah I still feel very tired
after the weekend and I would like to
play some games against you if you
challenge me and I would like to play
some chess 960 and some something a
little bit non-conventional and more
careful so if you if you like challenge
me to some chance 960 games and I would
do that yeah please play stronger
players it's a good idea but I don't get
any has we have seen and again I want to
do something a bit relaxing if you like
you like to challenge me to some 960
would be cool I'm just really tired and
I don't want to play
you know some title players and so on no
I'm not entire chest let's some chess960
is cool let's go
cool and see I have to look look for a
moment about enters this looks like
interesting I'm attacking a pawn and he
covered it okay so I'm trying to build
up a strong center okay I cannot go five
but I can develop some pieces and he's
attacking this okay I've got the f5
which lost active maybe Knight f4 is a
move we're taking G to that's a very
strange position very weird yeah
see I do a take that probably yes let's
take it and I put this onto here and try
to check is a-ticking for a couple of
times so I'm for feeding my castling
rights he can cancel okay
now I've been taking me five never
taking five him can I actually can so
long yeah I think I can yeah 97 defends
it I can cancel off some play have
switched places
okay Andrew yes I don't know if it's
good but it's always cool yeah I can
simply stop it in the queenside
twin side play because because I'm
trying to try to play on the when the
King saw it
g4 h 4 I would like to do that but where
it's a special placed best
he might be group the night to d4 huh
I'm trying this which would blunder
stuff okay hope I'm not blundering
blundering the house him he can try to
put tonight on to d4 and I mean he can't
he can't do that but I've got this this
is the threat yeah that's all the threat
to sorry this is covered yet the queen
is on that we date spot but then it's
always the some of those positions are
so bonkers I see I have no clue what's
going on get out of this probably it was
a questionable decision to give up my
dark square bishop now that I think of
this a little bit more closely okay age
for coming maybe I'm okay here maybe
yeah okay yes got this he's got this
yeah this this is this brutal approach
just sacrificing stuff to break through
not sure that this really works to be
honest
just at work I need to cover this pawn
down being ready for a one
yes discoveries but I don't see any
great great discovery twenty seconds
fantastic
very nicely played you like Whoville
each v hangs and ePHI things now at 100
I was a super super weird game very very
tough and nicely played a back wall
probably probably good prob probably a
pretty good player yes got good ratings
them okay so who else is challenging me
a BGP so what's going on here this is
looking the bishops have usual squares
okay I could go f5 and any castles again
let's let's control the center this will
look like a normal chess position very
quickly actually this will come here and
define and it centralized it looks very
very normal
I think cassia castling is fine just a
rook jumping over the king a good that
looks like a Kings Indian attack of some
sorts
got here but should be seven and so on
yeah like a ready opening let's cancel
schwa I don't know what the best time
control is to get games in chess960 on D
chest I don't have much experience with
before I'm trying to cut off this Bishop
interesting choice
and try to go F 685 I don't want to
trade more because he's got a bit too
many he's got he's good maybe too many
guy and I'm taking some some nice pins
going on here then I'm threatening to
use the pins this could be an idea and
this Bishop is also if he moves the
Queen away from the wrong leg and I just
take e5 take G - okay so 97 or 96 is the
idea I think this one
it's a bit awkward too awkward for white
he cannot move the Queen and everything
is tied together and fortunately for me
Queen to be age doesn't do much because
19c six is possible at least that
doesn't win stuff yeah he's very much
annoyed by this okay I can't go age 6-1
stop this for a moment
yeah chess960
and opening theory yeah I mean if
somebody is really like knowledgeable
about liens like he knows everything
move by move this is certainly removed
in some way but don't ya why this
running out of moves I'm just I can do
all kinds of improvement rules that is
stuck here and you can still real still
the use pattern recognition a lot and
there's no difference there that you
have patterns and and then ideas like
new concepts that still apply and so
knowledge is still helpful not so much
of move by move stuff but understand
concepts like here for example like g6 I
tried this to get play on that long
diagonal Oh Marco Rico is taking a long
time okay
yeah I don't know if these six like you
usually would play as good kind of
blocks this night
[Music]
oh okay I have to play a move that can
easily overthink okay so this is a tempo
they're probably a fairly useful tempo
let's get down yeah I'm I'm wondering
for porn okay yeah goodnight to
Christians Christian Sun 93 that was
probably a weird way to pronounce it so
[Music]
okay
I intend to play age sex and take care
okay which I'll push this back and now
yeah Bishop here is interesting putting
more pressure on you for no I can try to
win a for him
so I'm winning this pawn right
ah okay I have no idea what you're
talking about mint its drone so I have
no opinion yeah you mean I should start
an Arena on my streams yeah why not it's
it's not a bad idea
I don't think I will do one tonight
I'm not going to stream for a super long
time today also have to get up fairly
early night see to earlier one the
exchange really I didn't see let's see
three
okay so taking my pond here hmm
I know this looks very strange but okay
I'm still attacking this and he cannot
take on e5 because my queen is on f2
okay so I'm going to take okay that's a
good tempo a good tempo 96 maybe yeah
just take a just keep everything covered
give it to me the pawn I want to
checkmate here and I have always in for
those stupid tricks I can't help it my
tricks is tricks is really a bit too
much for that like one move mini ideas
okay anyway there is not much that
widest threatening I think so
I might as well try to snatch a pawn all
right yeah
DFO he tries to she tries to make me on
the info Oh God
it's pretty bad and I didn't have no
time
ha I was expecting rook a1 I thought you
wanted to try to meet me on the FL and
i-95 I've got Queen c3
it's not a big issue oh not good not
much
at least that's increment so I'm not
just losing on time position is
extremely critical though I saw that
this was hanging when I wanted to free
the position somewhat 14 seconds
no ever as he has a check oh my god
very nice job here by Marco Rico the
dead looks bad bad bad bad
yeah what the heck
very nicely done
it leads to a two to two and he beat me
two times I don't know what time
controller one was that anyway no I
don't want to be managed sorry I just
want to see some other challenges so um
kuk-ja probably not
Metrix untidy
let's go dutch let's go dutch
yeah that looks a little bit like a
leningrad touch it with f5 and so on
it looks fanny okay yeah black sorry
white can't cancel long now right that's
a funny way of doing it on more form but
there is this gain space in more space
that's a pretty awkward pin huh let's
see maybe I can bring my knight here
back to it to cover it maybe 95 is an
idea actually
what a wacky position
I looked extremely strange I absolutely
hate this pin I absolutely hate it feels
like I'm losing material every every
second
okay I really want to go g5 ready to
spin please yes so I got dissing at
least I don't know if it's good though
oh I did not repeat did not see this
check aha crazy okay yeah he's got his
six I know but I've got III this is not
super clear as long as there's the porn
only three white is completely crammed
you're on a king side huh not it's not
entirely clear so I can castlelong here
also probably will play Queen G - what
no yes f5 in good squeeze
well it is not enough it is not enough
unfortunately
no I totally blunder he takes e5 check
sorry what
who takes there I was just like pre
moving bishop take their five like every
normal person will play that and he
didn't okay that's fantastic
now I'm the rook downright what a crazy
game yeah anyway it seems like I'm too
tired to play anything remotely decent
now there was a weird that's weird
xuxa
yeah I don't know I should probably just
resign but as long as the position is
somewhat right yeah it's somewhat weird
I'm not doing this just not resigning
yeah but there's really nothing I can do
yeah yeah nicely played the chip shop
and so there's one more challenge am in
for a 960 game and after that I'm going
to watch a couple of minutes again on
that match then I'm alphabet one f3
three okay what if I just lost
everything open he tries the same it's
probably bad
I had the bishop takes actually just
heaviness hanging poo
she was also hanging
no moobot I think I would need to
install a board and I don't have a board
installed
yeah hello to all scratch I can take
here and I know of it's good though but
I'm going to take it such a weird
position as usual
maybe I should have played nine hours to
try to take with the night it was
probably strong
so let's castle
the realest thing about this place the
Knights in the corner I just like so
awkward yeah okay I got some play again
see two rookie one seems likely and you
can actually argue that this wasn't such
a great idea to be honest I don't FY is
a bit unstable
yeah not so easy my pieces are not well
coordinated full-time I feel like I
could blunder blunder something
because of this non coordination this
may be 97 even
[Music]
just want to open for the bishop okay
very sharp yeah Queen h4 is closed it's
close to working
Chris not sure what it actually
threatens him
okay so just take here on
[Music]
no that didn't really work out
III can just take yeah yeah yeah maybe
he could have taken the night but I ever
have a good attack it's not like I have
nothing it's not if it wouldn't have
been a force to win no anything like
that it is three zero action name time
now I'm not playing well at all I still
could get in trouble because of the long
diagonal I would just resigned
it was very healthy that was very
forthcoming no rook g1 is kind of hmm
yeah okay so before I enter the stream
I'm going to have a look at this mess
and it's so close it just closed Magnus
is leading by seven it's not he had a
huge run leverage which we witnessed and
after that it was more more points for
fat for for the pen penguin GM
yeah you know I'm not really much into a
chess variant so I don't have a clear
[Music]
opinion there you should implement new
ones or I don't play much myself and
just 960 it's not really a chess variant
to me that much it just mean it says
regular rules and nothing crazy it just
the different starting positions but
like introducing new places and and
things like that not not much for me I
think crazy house can be quite fun but I
have no one expertise yeah I've played
some games but I'm not good at it or
have any any particular idea how it
should be played so a king's indian with
a man weird line
nicely played here maintenance is trying
to round up my spawn and probably he
will get it root gate 5 as an additional
idea yeah
here we come and c5 is dropping
there's actually his - teacher - nicely
played game and his idea was I don't
know if it is technically sound with -
is doing you know it is getting a couple
of pounds and we'll definitely have some
compensation the bishop on d4 is
immensely strong and I think that was a
bad idea no black is probably winning
maybe he was anyway with here it's very
likely yeah there was a nicely played
game by Magnus you've got a card
switches structure but counts go for the
f3 before Crouch getting a nice central
advantage yeah it looks like why it
should be somewhat better I'm not sure
how much better
sometimes those positions can be
extremely resilient for black him like
if Black gets a blockade on e6
it's all fine but it looks too active 97
years 96 em and now blackest is pinned
yeah all over the place 94 nice shot but
does that work Mike can still just put
more you know 95 wasn't working anymore
but taking a Tengiz defending this
really nicely route g7
oh this is even stronger yes nicely done
yeah nicely done by white so Magus is
leading by nine yep I'm not in the
library this is just my office and yeah
I'm getting rid of gooks all that time I
only saw a 40 or 50 years of roughly 40
books last Sunday just don't know what
to do with it just too much and this is
this is all chest
[Music]
yeah um I've gotten rid of many books
chest books and also have gotten rid of
basically all of my novels because I
felt some years ago that I'm not going
to read any novel twice or three times
or whatever so I basically sold
everything that I had which was really a
good thing to do I had to hundreds
hundreds of books and I know I've got
much leaner let's say set up at home I
don't have that much stuff before us
hanging was Chuck Wow
we take they have six is made threat
yeah it's the problem you know counter
tech public renoise
I don't see one yeah it's really really
well defended by by penguin at the end
he couldn't come I could hold it but I
was really a great defensive effort nice
shot
yeah black looks fine yeah whites
position he has one issue it's just a
bit loose him the king on f2 is loose
and it should yeah I also read some
books more than once but you know if you
if you're sitting on hundreds of books I
didn't know how many were had but it was
a lot you really think oh my god do you
really need all this to be good are you
going to read all this three or two time
I don't know so I was just making a
clean cut I also saw it on my CD some
years ago I've had roughly 1,000 CD
Center and simply so autumn you get
editor but digital copies of everything
I really might really like and the rest
just I just got rid of yeah this looks
nice for white actually white has this
double palm but it gives additional
space it's not easy to play for black
but I noticed that yeah and Rohtang is a
really excellent at defending positions
with no time
it's really amazing that he's holding on
and some of those bad positions really
nice I'm not saying that he isn't bad
positions all the time I mean it's it's
very open but he's really holding on for
a long time in situations ways under
pressure a lot like this game he was
really in trouble and now we think he's
better
maybe yeah black is better I think maybe
the gbg pawn will do some trickery
because I know one night and wind yeah
sure I also would it would be fantastic
if they would play em and somewhat
slower time control I absolutely agree
yeah I think after this game are going
to call it a day as mentioned it was
really a long weekend the Sunday was
very very tiring and we had a league
match and we lost this match by the
narrowest possible margin and it was
pretty it's always it's always
exhausting let's say if you lose a match
like again by half a point
it really feels like oh my god what a
waste
so let's see if black can would draw
here somehow
no Magnus anyway another pawn that
should be a windfall for white for
Andrew ten metals fishermen night mate
would be fun but White has too many
pawns and he wouldn't do it in seven
seconds our God is really quickly the
mouse that's crazy how many moves to
they make Andrew crazy crazy okay guys I
hope you enjoyed the stream it wasn't
such a section on water and there was a
big bit of a mixed bag I still hope you
enjoyed it and yeah I'll be back
certainly next Monday maybe later the
week Friday could be an option I've done
some Friday's dreams lately but it's so
ready to say I don't know when how it
will work out
thanks a lot for watching I hope you
will make it next time bye bye